loaders provide a framework to perform
asynchronous loading of data they are
registered by ID with a loader manager
which allows them to live beyond the
lifecycle of the activity or fragment
they are associated with in addition to
loading data loaders include mechanisms
to monitor the source of their data and
deliver new results when the contents
change up till now we've used async task
to load data from the Internet in
sunshine we typically create our async
task in the oncreate method of our
activity it starts a thread which begins
a background task if we rotate the
device or do something else which causes
the activity to be restarted will create
another async task to do the background
operation will create extra network
usage or file system usage as both
threads run in parallel and it will take
a longer time for the user to see the
result of the load the async task loader
implements the same functionality as
async task but because it's a loader its
lifecycle is different with an async
task loader once we rotate the device
the loader manager will make sure that
the old loader is connected to the async
task loader equivalent of on post
execute the onload finished function the
loader thread keeps running in the load
and background function and once it
finishes the activity gets notified
through onload finished cursor loader is
derived from async task loader but has
an additional optimization if the cursor
has already finished loading and loading
background before the activity restarts
the cursor loader recognizes this during
the loader initialization and the cursor
is immediately delivered to the UI
through onload finished